this is the theme the things you there's
no this is the things is the thing
bismillah al hamdulillah peace be with
you starting with peace that's what
Islam is all about the way of life that
calls you to submit to the one guy the
creator of all that exists to have peace
with your Creator peace within yourself
then you can have peace with everyone
around you but you've got to do it what
you got to do a jihad or what that's
right you gotta struggle to do that you
got to struggle to submit because it's
easy to submit to your lower
inclinations that a lot of times it's
not good for you you want to go chase
that man or woman outside of marriage
you got to do a jihad against that to
stop that you might want to other utter
a curse word something that really
should not be coming out of your mouth
you got to do a jihad against that Islam
is calling you to do a jihad yes but
there's something that's been a trim
attributed to it it's anonymous now is
it with terrorism terrifying people
things blowing up or the opposite you're
about to learn the truth here on the
Dean show with my next guest we got a
surprise for you don't go nowhere this
is the theme the theme
no this is the things is the teacher
this is the thing is disturbing this is
the assalamu alaikum peace be with you
walaikum assalam warahmatullahi / God
who peace be unto you tube thank you for
joining us now let me tell you something
there are many people to have this title
I think you're qualified because other
people they use the same title so but
you prefer not to be called by sheikh or
mallanna or Mufti you got the knowledge
you prefer just to be called brother
Imran so I'm gonna call your brother
Imran mashallah ya brother and I prefer
being called as the student for Islam
and comparative religion I think that's
the greatest honour to be a student of
knowledge forever masha'Allah
masha'Allah masha'Allah God willed it
and we started with peace I started to
show a piece is it true that Jesus and
all the prophets they also started their
greetings with this when they excrete
each other with the audience to you goes
if you read the Bible you will find that
when Jesus he greets his disciples he
says a Shalom Aleichem and that is a
heavy connotation very close to the
Islamic Arabic term as-salam-o-alaikum
which means may peace be unto all of you
mushroom and that's very deep and we
want peace first and foremost with the
crater the heavens and the earth very
true so we can have peace within
ourselves because a lot of people aren't
on xanax they're Restless and her
nervous because they don't have that
peace so this show is about promoting
peace people to come to this realization
that there is a purpose in life and the
best want to tell you is the creator
that has literally so then you can have
and you could be living purpose and you
can have peace but a lot of times you
know what what distracts people is the
desire the desire now to want this and
want that things that aren't good for
you drugs alcohol gambling all the bad
things so you got to do a jihad
against these things are true but now
people are taking this beautiful word
jihad and you're scaring people with it
they think jihad is synonymous with
terrorism killing innocent babies kin
innocent people so you're here on the
show to clear up the fog to clear up the
false fallacies and misconceptions and
explain to us really what is jihad de la
de la hey la honda lillahi rabbil
aalameen what's allowed to was salam o
Allah Rasool he'll cream while he was
happy here at my in all the villa he
measured on the regime yah yah ladina a
menudo cool official me kapha velocity
bo karate Shaytan in adobo mubeen
rubbish Crowley's a dreamer yes silly
Omri voila la familia sunny Oahu holy
respected by the ed and all my dear
viewers I once again welcome all of you
with Islamic greetings as salaamu
alaikum warahmatullahi / kaoru meaning
may the peace mercy and blessings of
Almighty God Allah subhana Allah be on
all of you masha'Allah you have asked a
very important question on a very
important subject in a modern scenario
the Arabic word jihad is unfortunately
being misunderstood by a lot of people
being misrepresented by a certain
section of the media worldwide it's
being mistaken especially by a large
section of the non Muslim society
considering jihad as a holy war a war
against the non-muslims this is very
unfortunate see there is a saying there
is a popular saying in English it's not
the activeness of the rascals that
spoils the society it's the inactive
pneus of the good people that spoils it
say there again that's a nice so it's
not the activeness of the rascals the
Roscoe's like a mischief-maker a
mischief-maker here it's not the
activeness of these mystic mongols that
spoils the society it's the activeness
of the good people like us the muslims
who aren't inviting the non-muslims to
islam not educating them about the right
concept of islam and that is causing all
the problems in the world today so true
so it's very important that we need to
educate the people around us we need to
go out not I so
our selves from others and a time when
this word has become a synonym to
terrorism it becomes the duty of every
one of us to go out to our non Muslim
brothers and sisters and educate them
that jihad is something that even you do
every human being does jihad you see the
Arabic word jihad is derived from two
root words jajaja and jihad it means to
try strive for something and to strive
against something it student when he is
preparing for his exams he is doing
jihad he is striving for scoring good
marks for student in school of course
when a student prepares for the exams he
is doing jihad he is striving for
scoring big marks and a policeman when
he is trying to catch a culprit when he
is trying to arrest a criminal when he's
trying to maintain the law and order the
policeman is doing jihad against a
criminal so if you see the Arabic word
jihad would literally mean to strive for
something or to strive against something
as far as Islam is concerned when it
comes with the Islamic connotation in it
as an Islamic terminology the Arabic
word jihad simply means to strive for
all that Allah commanded as good the
Almighty God commanded as good to the
entire human humanity and it means to
strive against all which Allah
considered as evil for the human beings
and of course the Almighty God being our
Creator has the best right to dictate
terms to the man what he has to do and
what he hasn't required to do what he
should not do so that is very important
so jihad is a pure concept of striving
for something good and striving against
that is evil and every good is
beneficial to the mankind and every evil
at one stage of your life will destroy
the human population so that is what is
jihad and we truly need to understand it
in a little broader
are in a little more classified
perspective so that is how i would put
the word jihad as an explanation
initially i think look what you just
said is brilliant it's the fact it's not
fiction and you define this word just by
defining the word jihad and you gave a
wonderful eloquent example about a
student doing jihad not to cut school
not to go ahead and be with bad
influences being on time to class a
jihad it's a struggle and the policeman
against the criminal doing jihad
beautiful there's one thing also I
wanted before we go to break there's a
lot of times I don't let people get away
with this I'm not going to let you have
any special exceptions you said
something in Arabic in the beginning we
got a lot of not yet mrs. people who
everyone has a potential to submit to
the one guy many have after hamdullah
watching the show so just I don't think
you just worked a spell on him he says
something Arabic what did you say yeah I
just began when I said al hamdulillah
her balala mean it would mean all
praises are for Allah the creator of the
universe the Cherisher of the universe
but salatu salam ala rasulillah cream
may the peace and salutations be on the
beloved prophet muhammad salallahu salam
o allah allah he and on his family was
hobby and all his muslim companions the
male and female muslim companions that
is the sahaba-e-kiram because in la
jolla animas mine and then i recited an
eye out of the quran from surah Baqarah
sir number two at number 208 there Allah
Subhan O terra remains the Muslims ya
aur ladina al- to Koufos silma kapha o
you who claim you are Muslims enter into
Islam completely and perfectly not just
on Ramadan yeah not just in rooms are
not just by claiming not just a mouth
lip service yeah but do it in actions
because if you do it in action then the
peace will spread then the people will
understand ok this is a religion of
peace so that is what I recited o you
who believe enter into Islam
wholeheartedly and do not follow the
footsteps of Shaitan for verily it is an
open enemy unto you that's the Deaf was
the message I gave in Arabic from surah
bakra row number two out number 208 view
that is what I beautiful buechel so he
didn't work no no math later on I'm a
dad one of musa alehsalaam he made a
supplication praise give a beautiful
application you know it says rubbish
Raleigh sorry overlord open our breasts
for us open my best for me and made me a
person of courage expand my breasts with
knowledge while you're silly Emery and
made the task with which I am here easy
for me wanna look at Emile asani remove
any impediment in my speech any
obstruction in my speech to convey the
truth for Yahoo Foley and open the minds
of my listeners and the viewers to
understand the message and passing on to
them amazing amazing you learning so
much here on the D show and God willing
to learn some more don't go nowhere I
solo indios adorable era solo ya na Suk
lesson I would go to my room lock the
door prostrate and cry thank God you
know me better than myself show me the
right way and I will not look that I
will leave everything behind a lot of
that crater and it creates everything it
gives intelligence to people mohammed is
one of the last messenger since we got
back here on the d show with brother
Imran hamdullah I'll praise to the
crater of the heavens and earth that's
on erdus here with your presence thank
you for finding time to be with us on
the Dean show we're talking about jihad
so you also mentioned people say gee had
and then they put next to it holy war
jihad holy war absolutely very important
question and a very major
misunderstanding that was propagated by
the Orientalists against Islam you would
be wondering that according to The Times
Magazine a very popular magazine in the
u.s. dated 16th appeal 1979 it states
that in 150 years alone that is between
1800 Christian era tu 1952 severa 60,000
books were written against Islam 60,000
steeped oven and if you calculate it by
the number of days in this 150 years it
would be more than one book being
written per day against Islam and
sometimes I say to some people back in
my public talks I say if that would have
had
with any other ISM on the world in the
world that ISM would have become a
museum piece by now you would have a
vanished yeah I mean if the children
would ask what was this you will have to
take them to the museum to show but it
is the truth from Allah that is still
making Islam stand and these 60,000
books I think the Muslims would be
wondering 60,000 books and how do we
answer them so on a la shared one book
the Quran is enough to answer them and
you ask very important question about
holy war see the era the arabic
translation for holy war will be
horrible mukha visa and this word
horrible mojados are does not occur in
the entire Quran for one single time not
a single place in the entire quran the
word her bull moose adasi has been used
not even in one authentic teaching of
prophet muhammad aslam has this word
holy war been used in fact if you look
the history of the word or etymology of
this word it was crying in fact for the
Crusades the Crusades yes so nothing to
do if you sound you know with Islam
absolutely horrible mahadeva or holy war
has nothing to do with Islam at all not
a single time is it used in the Quran or
the authentic teachings of prophet Moses
llam amazing amazing facts not fiction
yeah this is a fact close but now
someone says you know what ok ok you
know struggling you know at school this
is good and you know to to go ahead and
for the police off for example example
you gave but look they say you know look
it Osama bin not and look at the the
World Trade Centers what about this they
said they did a jihad what you gotta say
about those someone like you this is
this I think that September 911 incident
and all that is happening up to
September 11 has brought the entire
Muslim Ummah on the back foot but always
we should be optimistic there are a few
things which very honestly everyone
needs to understand every anti-christian
every non-christian is not an
anti-christian every non jew is not an
anti chew every non-american is not an
anti-american
come to this country this the second
time i am visiting this country I love
America it's a beautiful place the
people are wonderful here it's lovely to
interact with them the reception they
give to whatever you speak to them the
way they host you as a guest it's
wonderful so but i am not an American
non-american but I'm not an LTI miracle
I am a non British but i am not an anti
British similarly it is very important
it's very important that every person
who is a non-muslim should understand
that when he says or when she says he or
she is in non-muslim the Muslim never
perceives every non-muslim as
anti-islamic we never say that the Quran
never says that how these people say is
that if you read the Quran you will find
a las 10 dolla commanding jihad in
several places in the Quran if you read
surah bakra so our number two number one
language so rep across or number two at
number 191 so epic are a certain number
to a thermal 192 surah bakra so remember
to ask number 2 body boo today mrs. for
a number for a thermal 74 surah Annisa
suriname before at number 86 sorry nice
ass for number four I've number 76 so
releases for a number for out number 94
for a nice ass or number four at number
95 so r anissa suriname before at number
100 so remind us for a number five at
number 35 sorry unfiled for a number
eight at number 72 so and falls for a
number eight at number 74 it's mentioned
in surah taubah soro number nine at
number five and six in surah tauba surah
number nine athame 20 and so at Ava's
were number nine at the mo 41 in surah
tauba us for a number nine at number 81
in surah tauba surah number nine at
number 111 in surah Hajj surah number 22
at number 58 and at number 78 inferring
who do not so number 49 Adam of 15 in
sir a substitute a number 61 at number 4
and at number 11 in surah theorem for a
number 66 at number nine these are all
the places where Allah commanded the
Muslims to do jihad but believe me not a
single ad which says kill all the
non-muslims on earth on the contrary on
the contrary I challenge there is not a
single religious scripture except the
Quran nor any law book on the face of
the earth except the Quran which has a
statement where Allah says the Muslims
in sir a Midas or a number 5 at number
32 if any
one of you save the life of any innocent
human being whether a Muslim or
non-muslim it is as though you have
saved the whole of humanity and if you
kill any innocent life whether of a
Muslim or a non Muslim in the sight of
Allah you have killed the whole of
humanity coming to Osama bin Laden and
the people who are labeled as terrorists
today see one thing is very clear for
the Muslims Prophet Muhammad is the
ideal Allah commanded in ouray ends up
short number 33 AD number 21 look at the
colonel a comfy rosewill in LA he who
swore to know Isana the best example for
mankind to follow is in the life of
prophet muhammad i say even the non
muslim brothers and sisters they should
study the life of prophet muhammad and
when they study that life if you find
any bin Laden or anybody incompatibility
with the Sunnah then you have on the
right to discuss Islam but if somebody
you find is not going according to Quran
and Sunnah you are most invited to
correct such a person to say that you
are not working according to Quran and
Sunnah so bin Laden and all these people
have never been an ideal to the Muslims
will never be an ideal in the future 100
bill nothings are born they can never be
an ideal to the Muslim community he was
right he was wrong there are many who
might think he is right there are many
in the world who think he is wrong for
as it is least important if he has
killed an innocent life in the sight of
Allah has killed all of humanity it's
wrong yeah there is goes and choice
about it if he has killed if he has
killed an innocent life he has killed
the whole of humanity that is what the
verbatim word of god now what you just
did I mean some people just got blown
away they're like wow are these
references that you were giving from
what we call and anyone can confirm this
who has an open heart open mind it takes
an analytical scientific approach you
are quoting the verbatim word of God the
Quran shibani you're giving references
yeah and that the ultimate source for
slum that's the ultimate source for
Islam anything everything a Muslim has
to do has to do it only from the Quran
and the Sunnah of Prophet Muhammad Saleh
solemn and authentic sauna and believe
me believe me p
like Osama bin Laden and these people
have never been the ideas to the Muslims
our ideas they're not our role models
what you saying yeah our role model is
the last and final messenger probe
Muhammad peace be upon him of course
who's a messenger like Jesus Moses have
no laws and they brought all the same
laws vetting teachings absolutely
absolutely the same teaching stair prod
and what was that teaching the teaching
of peace to the earth the teaching of
Islam to the earth that is what every
messenger of god brought the teaching of
Islam began from adam allah salaam and
concluded with the message of quran
being revealed to prophet muhammad aslam
who was the last and final prophet and
Messenger of Allah and Quran being the
last book of allah revealed as a
political as an economy as a social
justice system for the entire mankind
till eternity let's take a break shape
and we'll be right back he's like a la
here for more here on the D show brother
Imran and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the villages I remember find another
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender their self to cut is
a Muslim those who cemento submit to God
God's will die see Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God you create
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if a box but i
am not afraid to stay
back on the Dean show with our special
guests clearing up all the chaos and
confusion Islam is not calling a human
being to kill other innocent human being
is not about that you getting to hear it
here on the Dean show we define what you
had is a struggle and striving to do
good and to suppress the evil things
that you might want to do that you
shouldn't be doing and all the
messengers of God they call to Islam
submission to the one guy that's how you
have peace now there's some people out
there we don't know what's in their
hearts many people are going and
speaking about Islam they don't have the
correct knowledge about Islam so the
verses out of context they'll say you
know what what he's saying is baloney
and they'll say look at this verse
chapter 9 verse 29 or other verses and
say look it says kill them it says you
know kill the infidels all these other
stuff how do you combat this much alike
okay the lefthand see first of all as
anyone marie important thing is jihad in
Islam is done against basically four
enemies of God two of them are invisible
enemies of God you'll be wondering how
can we do Giada of them the first one
that you started the talk that is the
selfish desire when you fight against
your own selfish desire you want to
imbibe alcohol and you say no I am NOT
going through that you want to
intoxicated with drugs or something and
it said no no to drugs because allah is
watching me I feel Allah so this
struggle that I do against my own
selfish desire you want to commit
fornication or adultery and you said no
allah is watching me and not go do that
so all these kind of striving is jihad
against your selfish desire and the
jihad against the Shaitaan the jihad
against the Shaitaan because Allah said
that Satan has been given the power to
whisper and missguided the humanity so
Allah subhanAllah haces to do jihad
against the sheath on the site and might
whisper you and say nobody is watching
you you can seek a las forgiveness after
you have committed a sin not a problem
and you say no House bill like
missionary jail I think the protection
of Allah from this Shaitaan the s3 one
and when i do this i am doing jihad
against the Shaitaan the remaining two
enemies are visible the oppressors and
the hypocrites you see the opp
I sign the hypocrites can be amongst the
Muslims too so allah has commanded us to
do jihad against the oppressors and the
hypocrites but how to do the method has
been given in the life of prophet
muhammad sallallahu ala salam and then
the jihad that is the warfare method
which is referred in the Quran many
times as cattle meaning where you kill
your enemy or you get killed by your
enemy so many ayahs are there in the
Quran but a small statistic I would like
to give to you so he's go ahead Prophet
Muhammad SAW salam when he was alive 80
battles were fought 80 80 the puppets
are some himself participated in 27 out
of these 80 only nine were combats the
remaining didn't happen as a war at all
or there was no combat at all only nine
Conrad happened and the number of
enemies of God kill was only about 219
and the Muslim soldiers or the Muslim
Sahaba killed were a little above 100
look at these figures if you look at
this figures if Prophet was implementing
the Quran killing everybody the freakers
are totally opposite to what is being
claimed you look at what's happening
only in the last 100 years on this
planet earth in which we are surviving
if you check the First World War
nineteen fourteen to nineteen eighteen
the first world war according to
encyclopedia Americana it killed 21
million human beings I'm asking was the
Quran involved in the first world one
was anybody doing jihad in the first
world war one of the Muslims involved in
the First World War know if you look at
the second world war that happened how
many people were killed 1937 to 1945 the
figure of the human beings killed is
recorded in the Guinness Book of World
Record 56 million human beings were
killed why again I ask was the Quran
more than that but the Muslims involved
in that were they responsible for it was
it jihad know who killed them you were
fighting amongst yourself so if you look
at the figures only these two figures
the Russian Revolution the French
Revolution the war between I'd line and
British look
the number of people being get killed
where is jihad or Quran or Muslims
involved in these things they're not
involved it's just a media that is
defaming a particular teaching of Islam
and coming back again if you observe
here will find that the concept of jihad
is even given in other holy scriptures
please give us those you see Jesus
Christ my peace be upon him he's
referred as the Prince of Peace as a
Muslim I have no doubt he was the Prince
of Peace you see but the same Prince of
Peace he says in Gospel of Matthew
chapter number 10 verse number 34 think
not that I have come to spread peace on
earth I have not come to spread peace
but a sword a sword yeah that is what
and he's saying I have not come to
spread peace but still he is the Prince
of Peace I say if any Muslim is God's
this to say that Jesus was a terrorist
knows Bella may Allah forbid it's a sin
to me I am coding out of court as that
is what any Christian would sing jesus
says in Gospel of Luke chat number 19
verse number 27 bring that person in
front of me and slay him who does not
take me as a ruler over him that's Jesus
who is beloved to our hurts known as a
Muslim nation we learned all this so
slim is a Muslim if he does not believe
respect and love Jesus Christ Appeals be
upon him we Muslims we believe that
Jesus was a mighty messenger of allah he
was born miraculously to Virgin Mary
which many modern-day crystals do not
believe we Muslims we believe that he he
lead those who were born blind and the
lepers but my last permission we believe
that he gave life to the dead but by a
las permission will love him we love Him
in the category of all the other
messengers including prophet muhammad
sallallahu wasallam if you read the
Bible if you read the Old Testament in
the book of exodus chap number 34 was
from at 11 to 14 in the Book of Numbers
at number 31 verse number 1 218 in the
Book of Numbers chat number 31 33 verse
number 52 56 is the Bible now this is
the Bible the Old Testament the book of
the Jews and the Christians if you read
this was it say was to say hey I need in
the book of Deuteronomy chapter number 2
verse number 26 235 in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter 3 verse number 121
number 7
in the book of Deuteronomy chapter 17
verse number 12 was number six in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 20
was over 10 to 18 all these places Moses
may peace be upon him musa alehsalaam
has been commanded to attack the
inhabitants of the enemies and kill all
of them including their women and their
children this is the Bible this is the
Bible at the Quran not the Quran in fact
they have been commanded to kill all the
women the children and the men and leave
only the girls who have not gone to bed
with a man for yourself on the contrary
to this if you read say al-bukhari the
most authentic book on the compilation
of the teachings of prophet muhammad
sallallahu elsenham which is other than
the quran if you read it volume number 4
hadees number 257 and 258 the prophets
allah allah allah salam said it is
forbidden muhammad aslam said it is
forbidden for the Muslim soldiers to
touch a lady to touch a woman or a child
in the battle you cannot touch them if
you read other books of the teaching of
prophet muhammad aslam on his
compilations of his teachings he said
you should not attack the leader of the
really other religious groups if they
have not come to fight you you cannot
destroy the agricultural fields you
cannot pollute the drinking water of the
people you cannot cut down the trees you
cannot kill the animals which are for
agriculture purpose or for them to eat
you cannot touch the babies the children
and the women this is the teaching in
Islam which of these teachings i ask is
terrorism this is not an amazin amazing
the word terrorism has got more than a
hundred definitions according to the
United Nations itself these are amazing
facts and again not fiction we're out of
time for those truth seekers out sincere
people you know what now the fog has
been clicking see a little clearer they
like that Islam calls to to pure
monotheism not worshiping Jesus not
worshiping Saints and animals and
elephants and monkeys but only
worshiping the creator of all that
exists and doing good and doing the
jihad against the evil of your own self
that calls you to drinking and drugs and
gambling and doing an establishing noble
care they like this and you know what
there's still a little bit timid go
ahead and talk to them giving some
advice give them some advice
go ahead share I would just say one
thing the Prophet sallallahu wasallam
said in a Hadees recorded in CL Bukhari
volume number four at least number 667
ballyhoo Annie below ayah if you people
know one thing about Islam one thing
about me can be it to those who do not
know about it unless and until we
Muslims are going to do this job Allah
is not going to help us we need to do
every Muslim man and every Muslim woman
needs to do this we need to go out to
over non Muslim brothers and sisters
they are our brothers and sisters
because they are the children of Adam
and Eve they are the children of Adam
ala salameh nevarez salam and we cannot
see them being punished on the day of
judgment but not believing in the true
creator Allah subhanAllah and not
believing in the last and final
messenger prophet muhammad aslam and not
believing in the last and final
Testament the world constitution the
word of Allah the Quran which is for the
Peace of humanity if practiced in the
right perspective Eddie once again I
would just like to repeat one very
important thing I would like to
reiterate because I am in the United
States you are holding a show for me in
Chicago I really am thankful to you I
would like to reiterate that Islam is
not against every non-muslim just as
every non-muslim is not against every
Muslim similarly Islam and Muslims are
not against every non Muslim and there
might be disagreements with a lot of
things that we do in a family a husband
disagrees the wife a wife disagrees the
husband but that does not mean they are
enemies into each other so similarly if
Americans disagree too many things about
Islam and Muslims that does not mean all
Americans are anti-islam similarly if
Muslims disagree to American policies of
certain kind that should not mean to the
Americans that all the muslims are
anti-americans this is a very important
message I would like to convey to the
beautiful people of this nation the
United States of America thank you very
much my god oh mighty of the credit all
this is forging for be much thank you
thank you please be with you so I make
it and thank you again for tuning in to
the D show I'm so excited I'm so happy
you got to learn so much you got to
learn about jihad it's been misrepresent
you see now by just sitting patiently
through this episode you learn so much
and Islam is something that's for the
whole of mankind pick up a free copy of
the verbatim word of God the Quran 1 866
to Islam called the number call the
number and visit us here every week on
the Dean show until next time peace be
unto you